let's get into some notable discussions
that our audience is participating and
we do have a david pakman show subreddit
you can find it at david pakman.com
slash our IDI di t a few interesting
posts i noticed this morning one says we
should go to war with iran this is a
user who's making the case that listen
we took out Saddam's government in three
weeks his military was superior to
iran's that it's inevitable that they
are islamic fundamentalists who in their
constitution specify to spread islam
through violence and are not rational
actors and the idea here from this user
is it's inevitable let's just do it get
it over with and then move on and of
course a lot of people in our audience
pointing out that even if that's true
we'd rather someone other than trump
manage it like there's a lot of people
in our audience who are just saying it's
a bad idea to go to war with iran but
then others are saying even if we grant
the premises that you're outlining
trump's the last guy we want managing
that so it very interesting and agitated
discussion on the david pakman show
subreddit also it has been revealed that
the founder of home depot ken Langone
not languor as spelled on this tweet on
this post but ken Langone referred to
bernie sanders as the Antichrist in an
article where he was interviewed and
people calling for a boycott of home
depot I admit I sometimes do go to Home
Depot when I need I find at local
hardware stores that I've been to
provide absolutely horrible service
mm-hm so I actually am a customer of
home depot but referring to Bernie as
the Antichrist I find that off-putting I
will admit is it off-putting I don't
yeah I think it's that bad really
it seems pretty bad it's like when the
the nuts would say Obama is the
Antichrist I wouldn't go in and do
business with them if they if they had a
business which most of them didn't but
glad to know about ken Langone another
post on the David Pakman show subreddit
pointing out that Bernie Sanders
recently said there are some people in
the Democratic Party who want to
maintain the status quo they would
rather go down with the Titanic so long
as they have first-class seats I like
that quote
and what it's in reference to is the
blame effectively of the Democratic
Party for policies that aren't in line
and we can we can put that back up there
a few other bullet points here policies
that aren't in line with what most
Americans support being overly focused
on the Trump Russia connection accepting
and courting courting the wealthy for
donor money continuing to hire useless
but expensive political consultants
basically pointing out the problems with
the Democratic establishment you know
I've talked about this before I agree
that there are major problems with the
Democratic establishment but some of
these are just a little bit much for me
like I there's nothing wrong with fully
investigating Trump Russia collusion
let's continue to do policy let's
continue to prepare for the midterms but
the idea that that is merely a
distraction of the Democratic
establishment I disagree with but I
generally speaking agree with the quote
from Bernie that there are people with
with the relationship to the Democratic
Party is like wanting first-class seats
on the Titanic and lastly in relation to
Jared and Ivanka Trump an article
pointing out that they were recently
blessed by an Israeli rabbi who once
compared black people to Monkees yeah
the hangers-on that surfaced as a result
of the move of the Israeli the US
Embassy in Israel from Tel Aviv to
Jerusalem are just really vile
characters there's not only this Israeli
rabbi who once compared black people to
monkeys that blessed Jared and Ivanka
but we also had Robert Jeffress who said
Jews are irredeemably going to hell
brought to actually participate in the
opening of the embassy in Jerusalem we
had John Hagee who I don't even remember
his full list of just absolutely
horrible comments about who Jews he was
involved in the opening of the embassy
in Jerusalem it's a just a horrible and
disgusting cast cast of characters and
I'm glad that people on the subreddit
are pointing this out you can join the
subreddit more than 6,000 of our viewers
and listeners regularly participating
now at david pakman.com
/ reddit